هنا برشلونه حيث ولد الطفل الوسيم ابن
العائله الثريه جيرار بيكي الذي عاش طفوله
مثاليه في كنف ابيها رجل الاعمال والمحامي
الناجح وامه الطبيبه ليكون من السهله
عليهم انضمام الى الاماسيه اكاديميات
برشلونه كانت الحياه تحبكي الصغير نجاته
من الموت المحتم بعد سقوطه من شرفه المنزل
والغيبوبه التي دامت يومين جعلت منه الفتى
المدلل للاسره الغنيه ليكبر وتستمر ملعقه
الذهب في فمه ولان اصعب مدارس كره القدم
كانت لمياسيا كان على بي كي ان يحارب على
مركزه
واروح بقى فتره صعبه في الشباب انتقل فيها
الى مانشستر يونايتد ومن ثم الى نادي اخر
عادا جرار الى بيته الداخل برشلونه يبدا
مسيرته التي امتدت السنوات محققا فيها 33
لقبا مع مختلف الفرق التي لعب فيها
واكثرها طبعا برشلونه
اداره الاعمال يؤسس امبراطوريه ضخمه من
الشركات ومنها شركه الالعاب الفيديو
وماركه مستقله للنظارات الشمسيه مكتب
للمزايدات الرياضيات اضافه الى شركه
عقارات ضخمه الى جانب شركه تملك حقوق بث
منافسات البطوله لرياضه التنس وايضا بيكيه
هو رجل سياسه يدعو دوما لحكم وكاله
كتالونيا الذاتي هو وسعي لاداره برشلونه
مستقبلا بدا خطوات العمليه بهذا الشكل
كمؤسسا لشركه كوزموس القابضه وصحبه عبرها
على نادي اسباني
زومبا اشترى نادي جمال مخططا للمنافسه
والتوسع في مشروع رياضي جديد ولعل الصدمه
الكبرى في حياه جيرارد كانت بعد انفصاله
عن نجمه البوب العالميه الشاكيرا بعد
سنوات من الحياه السعيده اسريا تحطمت
الاسره المثاليه على حجاره الخيانه التي
جيرارد
بتبدا مرحله جديده في حياته عنوانها
اعتزال العشقين كره القدم وشكيرا